all i've got written on the board is hey
remember this is the notation that we
use what does it mean
what does it mean there are at least two
ways you could describe
what number this actually is when you
put something in n and you put something
in r
any takers
what does that
mean
can we give you a clue
one of the ways has to do with this
thing
is that jog some memory so this of
course is
pascal's triangle at least the beginning
of it so how does this connect to that
like what does this tell you
about that anyone
yeah
um
okay hold on a second one of the numbers
is how far down do you have to go down
pascal's triangle which number is that
though
it's actually n which
is a little confusing why didn't they
say r is the row but whatever it's the
convention i'm going to stick with it
because otherwise we'll get even more
confused
this is the row that we're on uh by the
way what's that row that row up there
that's the the zero throw then the first
then the second etc okay uh so that's
the road what's this guy
this is yeah how how far in is the r
term in the row okay so it's like how
far do you have to dig into
uh these guys over here until you get to
the one you want so as an example
what's that in ncr notation that number
right there on the end of the world what
is it
it's in the second row
and it's the
zero first
second term so it's two c two and
hopefully you remember
one of the things we looked at was n c
zero
any row
zeroth term
is always equal to
nc
m which is also always equal to well one
okay so we looked at that in the
properties of binomial coefficients okay
all right so far so good except
apart from actually just like you know
drawing all the rows out which is
literally what you did you guys still
have your piece of cardboard by the way
you got it there
uh you actually should get out because
i'm going to refer to it very shortly
apart from just drawing the damn thing
we have no idea what mechanism is going
on underneath here that gives us
whatever those numbers happen to be uh
you know 6 15 20 15 6 where they come
from
in particular and this is also something
i'm going to get out how does this work
out
what
mc whatever
is um is it drawing a big pascal's
triangle in there is is all that just
put into memory how's it gonna do it
so i'm going to show you now
what the definition of this is
and it requires factorial notation okay
now remember i said to you i wasn't
going to solve all the mysteries today
but i'm going to solve some big ones one
of the mysteries i'm just going to leave
sitting for a moment is
why
this definition is what it is you're
looking you'll think
what's going on there okay why is it
that particular arrangement
i will answer that question in due time
but for now here's the definition
starts with n factorial so that's n
times
n minus 1 times n minus 2 all the way
down until 3 2 1 and then you stop okay
you divide that by
whatever this
term along is
r
factorial and there's one more thing on
the bottom another factorial
the difference
between this number the rule you're on
and the number that you chose okay now
that's weird and it's just going to come
out of nowhere i promise i will explain
why this is what it is
but we don't quite have the machinery in
the understanding to build the
foundation yet we'll get there let's
just quickly confirm that it works uh
you guys have your pascal's triangle
there let me just draw a few more rows
here
okay so for example
that guy
right there
what is it in ncr notation
look carefully
row number
four term number
three
three okay so that should be as an
example
for
c three yeah like that's what it is in
this notation so let's just see how that
works with
this idea with the factorials that i've
introduced it should be four factorial
on help me out
three factorial
four and then this thing will be four
minus three right
which of course is just one
is that okay you see how i've just
substituted in that's all and so i can
use the techniques we looked at in
period zero this morning to unroll this
thing and start to simplify it out
without calculating the whole thing what
would i do with this numerator
it's four
times three factorial yeah
i've already got a three factorial there
one factorial is just
it doesn't matter so i'll just just
write one so you've got cancel cancel
the number that you expected
yes
let's try something a little further
down so how about here's an example
how about on the seventh row
let's get something
close to the middle how about this guy
okay now hopefully i mean you should
have drawn pascal's triangle far enough
that you've got this there but let's
calculate it and see how it works okay
7 factorial on the top there's the n
factorial tell me what's on the bottom
it's going to be
this number there's r
factorial and then you might have
noticed you see if you look at these
numbers
you look at these numbers what happens
when you add them together what do you
get
you get well
n minus r if you add after that the
minus r and the plus r they
cancel right so you just left with m
these guys are going to add up to
m
right so therefore these guys should add
up to
7 that's why this is 2 factorial is that
ok do you remember this morning we
looked at an example that was this
and didn't give that to you at random
that's one of the coefficients sitting
in pascal's triangle right you can work
out which one it is okay can we quickly
work this out
up the top there can we can we go and do
some of these steps in our hair i think
this is going to leave us with a seven
times six on the top once that five
factorial is gone
i've got two by one left on the bottom
so what's that
that's seven times three which is twenty
one does it check out have you got your
back to the triangle there sure enough
if you count along one two three four
sorry zero one two three four five you
get to 21. does that make sense